unable.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in
by authored by Abdim
Bedawi.
we have reached
or we are in the chapter regarding
the virtues of fasting.
We have be we had begun discussing
last night the narration of
in which Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
praises the fast
and the person who fasts
and in which the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam gives us
gives us
commandments
with respect to preserving the reward of
our fasting. And he says
that Allah says
[Silence]
He says that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
has said
if any of you is fasting a day
then he is not to engage in vulgarity
nor obnoxious or loud, rowdy or unruly
behavior
or engage in general acts or
discussions of ignorance.
And if anyone
insults him or attempts to argue or
fight with him, he is to repeat to he is
to repeat twice, indeed I am fasting.
Indeed, I am fasting. meaning to remind
himself and the other potentially and to
disengage.
[Silence]
Who are
He says, "And indeed I swear by the one
whom Muhammad's soul lies in his hand
that the smell of
the breath of a person who is fasting
with Allah law on the day of judgment is
more
is more desirable and is more and
is and smells better with Allah on the
day of judgment than the smell of musk.
Now some of the scholars
have taken from this narration, some of
the folk have posited
based on this narration here
that a person who is fasting should not
brush his teeth after a zel
after
basically.
Why is that? Well, they say, well, based
on this narration here,
the breath of a person who is fasting
is something that is desirable to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And if a person were to brush his teeth,
this would do away with this smell.
And we say okay why after
you say well usually that smell doesn't
start until after the why because the
stomach digests everything and empties
and then the smell starts to come up. So
it's a few hours after however this
even though it was posited by some of
the jurists of Islam
is rejected
and a weak opinion
even if only because of a lack of
evidence for it. This is conjecture
largely. Second of all, this narration
here,
this statement,
we have to take it in the spirit in
which it was intended. When the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam tells us the
scent, the breath of a person who is
fasting is more beloved to Allah on the
day of judgment. Not in the on the day
of judgment than the scent of musk.
First of all, he says with Allah, not
necessarily with other people, other
human beings. The reason he says this is
because it is particularly unpleasant.
Second of all, the spirit of this
narration,
is it that he is saying this intending
that the listener understand to not
brush his teeth? No, he is just
commenting.
Therefore, when we look at the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam's sunnah, we
see that he would brush his teeth, brush
his tongue while he is fasting and while
he is not fasting in the beginning of
the day, at the end of the day. The
scholars of hadith and the majority of
the fukah have rejected this opinion and
they say rather the sunnah of the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam is
that anytime there is a bad smell
whether it be in a person's body or a
person's clothing or person's breath
they are to do away with it right they
are to do away with it and this is
something which is obligatory
and
the prophet sallallahu alaii wasallam
used to brush his teeth while he is
fasting, while he wasn't in the
beginning of the day, in the end of the
day. And if this were what he intended
by this statement, we would find that he
outlined this clearly in his actions.
We look at
in his book,
we see that he says,
[Silence]
that he says the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam used to use a suak year
round when he's fasting and when he
wasn't in the beginning of the day and
at the end. This is largely conjecture
and this is not the spirit in which the
narration is intended.
I remember
you know this is this is particularly
important when a person is fasting
that a person observe
the etiquets of
or
and that is brushing the teeth and
specifically brushing the tongue because
that's where bad breath comes from. You
could brush your teeth all day and still
have very bad breath. And you could
brush your tongue and not your teeth and
not have any bad breath. And you could
use breath mints until the cows come
home and still have very terrible
breath.
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
used to
brush his teeth
and brush his tongue particularly.
As a matter of fact,
he would brush his tongue so far back
into his the back of his throat that he
would gag sai
while he is brushing his tongue in wub.
Right? Why is this? In order to
in order to remove any bad breath if
there were any. Right?
the statements of Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala.
It's one of the narrations with respect
to the meaning of this verse or the
reason it was revealed. Oh prophet, why
is it that you prohibit upon yourself
that which Allah has made permissible?
seeking the the
pleasure seeking the validation of
your wives. It said that and
they were jealous that the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam on Zanab's
off day would go by her house.
because you know each day he would
spend that night at the next wife's
house but every day he would stop at
Zanab's house not to sleep there but he
would stop there she would prepare for
him milk mixed with honey and that
was something that he liked a lot. So he
would drink it and then he would come
home and Aisha and Havsa were you know
jealous why is he going there on
her off day and you know women's stuff
and so they got together and decided
listen
let's
say to him that when he drinks that milk
and honey it makes his breath
unpleasant.
go because they know that anything that
would cause such a thing, he would avoid
it. Sai wasallam. The point is not for
him to avoid the honey and milk. If he
were drinking the honey and milk at
Aisha's house or Ha's house, he could
drink it until he were busting at the
seams. The problem is the problem is
Zanab's house, right? This is what do we
call this in modern terms call this
well jealousy but we call this passive
aggressive right passive aggressive I I
don't have a pro I don't have a problem
with that it's just that you know it's
the issue is not going to Zanab's house
that's fine you can go to her house just
don't drink the milk and honey right and
so when they insinuated this to him.
He stopped drinking that milk and honey,
something that Allah had made lawful for
him and that he liked. And so Allah sent
down,
why are you making prohibited upon
yourself that which Allah has made
lawful?
Seeking the validation and the pleasure
of your wives almost as if to say the
pleasure of your wife is something that
changes with the wind. It's not
something that you can that you can ever
truly secure.
So don't make prohibition and lawfulness
and unlawful based on the whims of your
wives.
This is a narration that is cited by the
scholars of Tiff. The point here of
bringing this up is that
that which is foul in smell, whether
it's a foul breath, whether it is a foul
smell, odor from lack of bathing or
clothing, or even if a person uses a
smell which is particularly potent and
unpleasant. Right? Even if a person uses
a smell which is unpleasant in the area
in which they reside some very strong
oud right which you can get from
places Cambodia and southern India
and so forth it smells very potent and
it's offensive in western culture. It's
not considered to be a good smell. It's
considered to be a noxious smell. And so
this the sunnah is to avoid that at all
costs. Always always to avoid anything
that would give off a bad scent
whether you are fasting or not. And so
when you are fasting, especially in the
morning, when you are going to have your
you finish your it is paramount that you
brush your teeth deeply with a deep
tongue scrub all the way back to the
back of the throat. and then brush your
teeth mildly throughout the day in
order to do away with any odors that
would be any noxious odors. He says,
he says, "And for the person who fasts
two, there are two
times of rejoice.
The person fasting will rejoice twice
for his one act of fasting. It pays
dividends twice fold in two separate
occasions.
The first is he will when he breaks his
fast he will be he will rejoice to the
breaking of his fast in the dunya and
when he meets his lord he will rejoice
for his fasting. So in the dunya he will
rejoice for breaking his fast. In the
hereafter he will rejoice for his fast
itself due to the reward and the
closeness that his fasting has brought
him in proximity to Allah's pleasure.
This narration has been collected by
both bkari and Muslim.
[Silence]
Oh, and just a reminder as we
announced previously that we will begin
the fasting on Thursday. We will begin
on Wednesday night. That is still
standing. that is still as it will be
in accordance with the
imam's council of Arizona that is
usually followed in previous years